this is so new no not yet
oh can you change it to the other one
wait sorry yeah here we go we switched
it up for now
this is so new see if people like it
we're trying something else there's a
lot of wasted space in our setup and you
know what else I notice is because we
took we we put the pit in the lower
right hand corner
but you guys have watermark so the
watermark goes like right over us now
which isn't great so this system should
be better for lots of reasons also the
game is you know not sixteen by nine
anyway so it kind of fills the space
better sweet
what we do last time are you got the
Eagle plate I got the Eagle plate I also
got kind of messed up I got I heard a
comment from someone in the youtubes
that said they think that I'm not doing
a really good job here like basically
the the critique was you're saving lots
of ammo but if you're getting injured
this often it's not worth it like if
you're constantly getting injured you
might as well just use the bullets
because at this point I have a [ __ ] ton
of bullets but I'm running out of health
like I only have I only have two health
options here I have to first aid sprays
and you know that's not great and I
think I'm I think I'm currently injured
yeah hopefully I'm not on danger yeah we
can kill more people I'm on caution so I
think I should be kind of F and more
people up but then I also got an inkling
that I might be up for like a pretty
major fight coming up soon
yeah and if that's the case I should be
prepared for such a thing with lots and
lots of ammo you don't need it yet guide
guide me you can use the evil plate on
the remember the door overpassed yes
yeah use that that's the one where I can
get stuff out of the I was putting stuff
in a metal detector or whatever so I
could go through the hallway is that
what you're talking about
it's that direction yeah yeah okay so
what do I need to do those like should I
should I bring some of these granado's
no bring a first aid in case I like
don't use it but just bring in case okay
should be good I did not equip convened
this real quick
and that's a quick
cool all right I feel good not great but
good I'm like I said I'm gonna be a bit
more like proactive of murdering today
oh and you got the lockpick which will
come in handy oh god I hope there's
health in that lockpick huh
like not in the lockpick in like some of
the things that I lockpick oh yeah in
the locks that I pick is what I meant
mm-hm oh if you're new to the show
there's a resin cannibal we play
Resident Evil here them bugs this way
right so here's a question should I kill
these things yeah sure
oh the Bandersnatch is wait oh no I'm so
dumb my very first choice you might have
to do some dodging in order to kill I
think I'm gonna Juke I have to Juke
because god bless you I have to Juke
because I'll be totally suck on the edge
of the stairs here so I have to kind of
Juke and then shoot them the problem is
their arms are so [ __ ] long balls
so I shoot him now oh she got me any
he's got me good [ __ ] you
don't hit me I shoot him from there
right which one were you hitting I mean
where is he I got him
I'm almost dead should redo it you want
where oh you can go in here shied redo
it how almost dead am i pretty almost
dead what do you think yeah you could
try again yeah just any old puncher Roux
I got it so all the way to the stairs
and just shoot like a maniac mm-hmm all
right I'm feeling up how's your week
good what do you do
finish them gotta for stuff for work did
like a behind-the-scenes thing with Cory
Barra like the creative director you can
write for state of decayed stuff doing
some zombie stuff which is always fun
it's cool talking about why zombie games
are still somehow popular they'll always
be popular yeah that's kind of the point
they're so good a lot of people always
say they're sick of them but like
everybody he's buying them it's true if
there was a left 4 dead 3 I would just
be like me me me me me me yeah it's just
the best game there's so many games that
are really good was that one um
beta decay tears coming out soon dying
lights good dying light was so good
they're doing like a mini battle royale
thing now yeah a zombie games are always
good no that's not true but they're
always like interesting no that's not
true zombies aren't really an enemy
they're more of a setting okay let's try
this again all right so I need double
Jukes
double Jukes
oh alright alright all the way to the
end [ __ ] this is my new system you just
try putting a handgun into that bullet
of you noticing how [ __ ] OnPoint my
counts are it's good nice yeah what you
got nothing you're gonna teabag that
banner Sanae ouch I don't know how
that's the closest I can get look at
what you can't have
it's like an emote check this booty I
hope this is worth it
I basically basing this yeah now you're
you're going back to the palace a few
times I'm basing this off of like I
think a pretty sound advice that's right
yeah this point you're getting hit every
time you go back and forth it ain't
worth it I think it's pretty apparent
yeah that your uh don't you get
what oh this is the right way no that's
really I don't remember all of what's
going on but I know that this is right
do you hear that sounds like cows
zombi cows all right so there's zombies
in here and now I don't know where to go
from here past the private residence no
not the private residence oh goes double
nice god bless it yeah you might as well
you're coming back through here kill him
first
um open your map it is it's it's the
other one yeah you're going tour that
item box in the bottom it looks like
[ __ ] where is this guy okay no no no
that's where you came from
it's back behind toward the camera down
left where's the side of that oh how
embarrassing I drop my bucho your boot
shot
mmm I think it's this way right yeah
short cut you open and then I killed all
the people in here
[ __ ] them yeah glia beautiful whoa no
that's [ __ ] what should I do come
back toward the camera probably yeah
just waiting there for them
what do you mean you kill them yeah hey
I can't see them you'll see I've got
enough space look to that just wait till
you see them they're not banished not
just you can kill them in like five
shots
[Music]
[Music]
what wow there's not coming they're so
dumb dumb idiots
but this camera angle is so stupid
[Music]
good
[Music]
look at his face it's probably from all
the shootings
[Music]
[Music]
I can't [ __ ] see this stupid
they did this on purpose
come on out you idiot
[Music]
like I don't know he's okay
yet you seem surprised that the camera
angles in this are not always confusing
the camera angles make it harder to
shoot the zombies it's like at the
horror game so annoying well check out
that guerrilla team you made check it
out
no I just I thought maybe there was a
secret
I wanted to say gwella team do you say
schizos no that's good cuz it's not
pronounced that it's not pronounced that
you didn't mean that totally calculated
Wow yeah that baby
[ __ ] alright so should I go in here
sure what is better in this situation
the bullets or the crossbow crossbow I
think crossbar more powerful but in this
situation I don't I probably stick with
them okay I can hear them they're
everywhere please don't be a bandar
solution
this place looks yuck first day spray in
that cabinet
and on rounds I thought so but it won't
let me pick it up covered in American
Wolf is my middle name I want to kill
this person that Ari
[Music]
put its place infirmary
yes this is it he does look like he is
doctors he will be animated at some
point he totally [ __ ] does see that
thing under here I want to pick it up
what's in here Oh God
I'm not but what's inside I look in this
does this all been looked at yeah that's
where we got the first aid spray
that's outdoors right no I don't know
what that is should I open it what is
this I'm gonna go in here first
Oh Lord what a horrible shitty ass
camera angle why with the colonel I'm
looking this sucks
Tom it's a Tom and the Tron there's a
demon in my mind with the demon in me I
enjoy watching people agonize Lord it's
giving me facilities chemicals and
equipment necessary to study everything
it is especially critical that no one
discovers the sacred place that only he
and I know about which is why I'm
writing it in my secret journal stop
reading now I swear the basement of this
medical building will be kept secret I
swear I hope no one reads this again
stop reading I keep the key with me at
all times even if an outsider sees it
they will never be able to tell that it
is the key all right so I got to find
the atop mists notice the autonomous
ease whew that eye looks weird
that must be though the eye you must
need to find an eye Hammurabi's code
Punk
oh I thought you could go in there
that's probably the basement he's
talking about can you go around the
right that you can't
all around the thing no go back go
around that thing doesn't go to the wall
okay I don't like this area well suck it
up
I know No
did you see that body bag man yep
your survey survey thought I don't want
to die roxrite him
yeah hey go light them up [ __ ]
a zombie Annie's on fire
böck what do you think he would go down
easier flames or engulfing him yeah
shouldn't they be the weak ones I'm
really glad I didn't eat that plant I
normally would in situations like this
because I'm not doing very well
health-wise I'm in orange caution so
this isn't great what do you think I
don't want to die
some having a good run think you're fine
for now Oh spike Arun
where's the place crematorium torture
chamber
they like tried to cremate them but then
like I don't know I feel like once
you're on fire like there it's not like
they patted themselves out or rolled
like they should have like burned up I
know
glad I'm finding bullets cuz I'm burning
through them this episode I opened that
she had a lockpick I forget how do you
sick combine that with a pistol and get
Joe upgrade with my pistol mm-hmm
how do I do that just combine venom
well first stop examining this one Wow
still staying on it totally yeah stock
Wow does it come with the earmuffs oh I
can't hear you chew into the microphone
because that would be sweet it's
different it's not earmuffs it's like
that year what Boba Fett's face oh
that's like an electrician oh yeah
execution chair for a short person like
welcome to my torture chamber how would
you like to go we have these giant
spikes you can just you know be stabbed
down onto one of them an electric chair
that one's very popular and then there's
this one where we just you know put you
in a pit and burn yeah let us know or
you can have your one star know who it
holds more bullets now
so the [ __ ] bag was moving so I know
that there's an alive guy in here that's
rude it is very stressful with people at
home oh god
[Music]
okay that's fine yeah
[Music]
is that burst or automatic I don't know
I just did that shoots nice oh there's
still another door outside you can go
through by the way yet you mean outside
you might as well get rid of the eyeball
right now while you're in here okay oh
that was stressful
hope you're not stressed out you need to
get some serious my creepy key so you
don't want me to go down there you MIDI
do the other door first okay let me go
down there check off all the boxes
here's the thing
is there a boss down there because I
should save there's not I know where the
first boss is the first second I guess I
haven't done it boss yeah I don't think
so this game's crazy
well yeah go - yeah sorry - camera
okay so there's explodey stuff here I
think right now that you have this
handgun you could start using their hand
bow again just to conserve ammo if you
wanna do okay should I go through yeah
what do you mean what do you want tell
me what to do oh [ __ ] keep out or Spock
[Music]
am I
Oh push that oh this is the door on the
other side of the control room where the
metal detector was should be able to
push that box
or climb over it yeah [ __ ]
does this it what oh it's a [ __ ] box
I'm cool I don't need all this right no
today yeah I would push that crate away
first
I don't know how is this like one of
those puzzles no good yeah go to this
side and then just push it just run up
against it without pressing X uh-huh
go on oh no you can't yeah you're right
I think on the other side you do it
maybe I have to pull it
no yeah go this way just walk up against
it from there you go
we're there we solved it Yahoo okay so
should I go through here yeah this is I
think you cleared it out unless the
other things have respond here this is
where you were I don't know I'm pretty
sure I killed all this [ __ ] this is the
other end of the metal detector hallway
pencils
oh cool I could say if if I had oh wait
no I can't say it okay cool
so if I should save you should let me
know like if I'm gonna die let me know
okay help me help you I hope this is the
one with them I wonder if you have
anything in the other one I do I have a
thing actually I can't remember I'm
gonna be honest with you well don't
worry about this don't but don't walk in
there yeah just go back this way we go
the long way around to check it was
there anything else in here and while
I'm here it's a 3d printer thing that
you already use them I remember that
grenades yeah I remember there were
times when we were like don't take it
now you know what I mean I think those
are the best kind of gray as well the
green ones arms annoying as [ __ ] we can
put we can put them in that bin so it's
really it's really convenient I do not
want to go in that basement what's up
with Knievel's in basements what okay
grenades do you have equip to the
grenade launcher right now none I don't
know people are saying that's the same
thing as the crossbow you can just put
infinite in it as long as there's one
type oh I don't know
blue grenade oh just wrecking it okay
you don't need that yet you will sir -
don't need anything else
[ __ ] you know what I realized what next
time you get arrows don't immediately
combine them with the crossbow gun
because I don't think you can make
explosive rounds
oh really separate arrows are you sure I
mean try combining them with the
crossbow well then I can't use my
crossbow cuz I'd be wasting it huh
are you talking about if I combine the
thing with this then I think I'd be
wasting them explosive arrows right no I
don't think so but just in case next
time you get them save them I mean I
hope you don't need a bit what a day
we've had
yeah well so far okay so I'm gonna leave
again
and we're gonna go down to the basement
and I'm not gonna die I guess for a high
five are you doing like that I'm asking
about what my chances are of dying oh
they don't want to die I feel like I
have a right to know I don't remember
you don't know what's down there do you
have health of you in the case that's
fine I don't remember what sound it's
not a boss fight like so you'll
or is it sorry
dying over here
No
just keep limping
God please don't sprinter [ __ ] they're
all gross look at them
I don't mind bats I'm just trying to
figure out where I'm going alright so
I'm just going straight to a door go
[ __ ] no they got me fake it weekend
I don't think what did not go well reset
reset and just get ready to shoot it
there's a lot of it was like three
that arrow just curved in the air did
you see that Ted it's just like that
movie where it is McAvoy wanted my
favorite movie yes no just kidding sorry
that's an office joke kind of they not
coming after me now it's like stuck on
something
okay listen you could probably hit one
yeah I heard that
oh no that's the wall yeah I hope you
like steel bolts in your mouth what is
this place that's November if this all
right maybe I should just dodge them now
okay so do not come VIN got it yeah
I would not dodge him
okay Boromir cool you dead
killing it um this place is scary is
this a door or where is this like a
curtain oh it's so thick you can
this is like a torture chamber lessons
sorry Sookie oh that's like a drowning
mechanism okay this is a strange device
holder this is a I mean what is that
it's not like for
is that just like a step
stepping ladder there's all this blood
here makes me feel like maybe that's
where you get shot or something I don't
know a door and then a wheel I think an
old water mill okay there's a lot of
unpack in this room go this way
[Music]
[Music]
was there there was no other places to
go right that's a and what is this okay
this is a place for you puzzle and maybe
die holding a helmet holding a shield
holding some armor holding a sword wait
hold on can you spin this thing it is
concerning okay don't kill me oh yeah
just push it or spin it oh my god
what that was it how was the dumbest
trap ever looks like the Cho gate the
boo box box I feel like I'm gonna come
across a letter later from that guy who
lost his eye he's gonna be like no one
can know the secret to stopping the
poison gas is by rotating it's been
spinning them adjust spend the night
until his face is used soared in there
looks like you know what your absolute
best that's a weird way to describe a
steel chamber I can put my little my
little combat knife in there by not what
did I accomplish
maybe something upstairs got view to on
everything no one got you that's the
fastest animation I've ever seen in this
game ah got the sword in him that's oh
he's not that and there's something in
the Chokey where is he
all right that's happening why was a
piano in palace but I forget where
bottom floor oh yes it was the room
toward where you got the Eagle plate I
think I've been wrong before though well
let's do that now you what can you open
that door now I'm here I wonder what
door
there's like that metal button outside
of it this room sucks I'm so scary
this has to do with the waterwheel
[Music]
there's more going on in here can I like
drop this just blood everywhere in this
room like I agree there's definitely
more to do here I just don't know what
yet later probably okay cuz now that I
have the piano we go to the palace and
you kill those two Bandersnatch is along
the way I did so I don't have to worry
about that anymore
make sure those banners snitches get
some bandages you [ __ ] bastards we
say bastards hey we should i had my
lighter such [ __ ] like why did I give
him though cuz you got an upgraded
handgun on it and explosive arrows good
bye Joey you do that you don't have
I said you're right feels good killing
stuff in this game where you all those
guys come from
I had already killed everything I don't
know
you are not on board that door it's
completely nailed dead it's impossible
to omit oh if only humans that invented
something that could remove nails
which one is it act or you got it ace
nice
I'm excited about what this uh song is
gonna be what do you think old-time jazz
Alt alt rock folk fusion polka tiny
polka polka polka you know polka eg we
poka poka poka very big in Sheboygan no
Sheboygan shaken very big in Sheboygan
she's like my favorite character
greetings
you must be the lovely Claire Redfield
I'm a ghost coming back to haunt your
dear well get his shoulders and his feet
it seems there's not much explaining to
do is there I was the one who attacked
decide who'd have thought you'll be
hanging about
can't track them this nice surprise
you're ever so caring brother who
definitely show up I must thank you for
being such good bait always got like red
eyes went on between you two but you
have them all wrong my brother is not
the kind of person you think he is
whoa I despise Chris what are you gonna
do to him whoa
rude I'm gonna make him eat my poop yes
he's gonna suck my toe thumb what stay
there I'm coming
Wow it appears you melee of some father
used to me I'm going to let you live a
little longer he say goodbye to my jello
that was dumb [ __ ] web slings away
what game is this she just stands there
like nothing happening I'm fine
that was weird he just like beat me up
what'd he say his name was Albert
whisker happen so fast man we've seen a
lot throughout this series killed him in
a volcano and five-o right still have
yet to plays Suns campaign in six I
don't know if I remember where this is
I'm gonna need your help it's in the
casino a opposite side of upstairs I
think from the save room it is upstairs
I was mine
it was like where the kids made out
right yeah no no sorry the piano is not
that's the private residence
cuz there's two musical boxes there we
check one you already put the red end
into cracks so ideally this would give
you the blue in or whatever I don't know
that that's what it's gonna happen but
this is where the piano is
good memory yes okay
did it it did it did it did it oh it's
blue man it's a bug
[Music]
[Music]
SiC you want to go put it in the thing
am I in danger do I need to save I've
done a lot so I really don't want to
have to know we can do a few more things
and then save where's the stupid twins
that turn into the save room and then
through the little gold Luger door no
there's a thingy in there yeah there's a
couple thing you use in there no yeah
it's one you could dodge it okay so it's
to the left go baby go that's
unfortunate
Kyle's slap little slap and pickle there
I don't remember where I am okay I could
do forward
he's burping every time you hit it
where's the sky sky oh my god
oh no don't use those it's too late I
don't know I'd like to use these bullets
yes I think I [ __ ] up that's alright
you'll find more there was like a
hundred bad guys in here all wearing
suits
yeah we're in nazi zombie territory now
so where do you think you're gonna go
next after this island if you were to go
somewhere else
what there's more what do you think this
was I thought this was it no I told you
last episode you really you were like a
third of the way through the game I
think you're no I mean I thought like
the island was it
oh no I've mentioned it a few times you
just might have not been listening what
it's I guarantee you you will probably
won't guess
yeah we forgot good we forgot are you
[ __ ] kidding me
who's next she looks so badass
I know it's like on her chest she's got
like a wider stance now hey vet hey bet
there's more about where are they
you check around down here last time
dottie did but now I'm like that door
yeah I definitely did oh is that the
Eagle plate room no no I don't mind
going in there there used to be
Bandersnatch --is in here oh there's a
lockpick in here I think okay I don't
know where I am oh wait man there was
like a lock pick in one of the rooms had
Bandersnatch is in it but we killed them
from one angle and nicked that cabinet I
forget
I killed two Bandersnatch a--'s in here
anything I remember Kevin the one with
the lady
wondering what would happen if you lit
that on fire I don't have my lighter the
biggest regret of 2018 that's saying
something
saving that man probably on the landing
of stairs
areas high fine I
Oh sketching you bet he's coming down
just let him come down and finish honey
I'm home
Oh husband that was the sound of a tool
chest holding down the Sears we're
having a really good time
well we're just a couple of kids aren't
we
someone's going ham on that organ sorry
lady tagging
eat eat eat eat here here this is always
here feel like it should have had that
more ingrained in my memory no idea it
was a really stressful thing to have
hanging from your feeling
hi I've got a beetle
trying to deliver this beetle cool cool
do I need the music hug do I actually
need music maybe do you have to like
open oh you probably have to open the
red one never you closed it to get the
in the other room I was born get the
music out of the red one music I thought
you can open and close the other one
maybe definitely need to do I don't know
I could be wrong
oh just like touch it touch it I guess I
can't remember I thought when I opened
it it played automatically there's two
of them but the other one was a red one
in the other room right go back to that
what I'm saying is I thought when I put
the bug on it it played but now that one
did maybe that that might have a
mechanism that this didn't do you
remember it's just like the same spot on
the other side of the hallway
well this area is so creep yeah yeah I'm
glad we didn't take that last time yeah
hang up space I wouldn't have thought
about it good thing we didn't think
about it
I think cuz when that opened it poof
just like hanging out and one is enough
for me got your plate
oh yeah you did do this on the other
side I forgot what you got though I
don't remember the reading but I
remember being stressed about it I was
like nobody wants to go up here that's
the creepiest thing they could have play
here
it is a gorgeous Wow
at dulcimer because zile xylophone is
doesn't that look like the photograph
from the ghostbusters 3 the one that it
comes to life it might be - I can't
remember the reason one with Kate
McKinnon and everybody right yes I think
you think of two - a dragonfly
Oh
it's very strange surprised me at the
tower from the beach from clock town
Majora's Mask where that dude is the
moon I don't like this whole thing all
that [ __ ] bag a picture of an ant is
drawn on the wall the P it appears the
keyhole is the mouth Oh
the Dragonfly is picked up hey try exams
you can't check it
looks like a key now right can you use
it also there's an upstairs oh that
makes more sense
what's up there
do you know what's up here you know
I'm hoping it's something like that
points us in the next direction because
right now we are out of like keys and
stuff I am boxed I mean that's nice of
them but currently we you're right like
we don't have like a place to go now
ten-year-old girl genius graduated at
the top of her class from a prestigious
university the International Corporation
umbrella Inc offered her the position of
head researcher no it's a movie box oh
there's a boot
[ __ ] no lady no lady gonna push it back
into it's original position first got it
I didn't exactly
baris cat
dad cats thank you stop reading my
sister its I would love her
I would overcome any obstacle and
willing to risk my life for her
I must revive the glorious Ashford
family we will restore a family name
once that has been achieved I will build
a palace where only Nobles may gather I
cannot allow the unwashed to see my dear
Alexia oh really get to say it like she
was right she reigns the world is Queen
as my dream I do it all for her oh hey
remember the videos the creepy videos
I'm pulling the wings off dragonflies
yeah that's why maybe that's why so you
have the army proof and the air force
proof so I have to right no you already
put one in so I have three please you
have to yeah yeah yeah no we have
everything that might be a place to call
that is the place to call it because now
we know what to do I'm gonna take both
proofs and we're gonna go to the
submarine and we're gonna put him in and
see what happens
shit's getting deep I'm pretty good
pretty good on health too
I wouldn't say I'm getting bored but I
was like cool I've done it and this one
was like this episode we like really
it's like you don't know what this is
about yet we haven't even scratched the
surface crazy
you saved I did save okay I done saved
cyber yeah I Oh coffee passion
Coffee crash sweet well thanks everybody
for joining us yeah awesome learned a
lot played a lot getting now we're gonna
do the sub next time so exciting
exciting stuff I'm really into this
you'll definitely have a boss fight next
episode I thought you might get those
subs you never crash if you just drink
beer instead of coffee I had a couple
beers earlier and yes you do crash
called a hangover terrible advice anyway
while she chugs that I'm gonna foul now
you're slipping it so girls drink with
moderation kids